hopefully this is enough of a prompt to
bring your mind back to visions you all
kinds of diagram different looking at
you remember what we call these is our
question Venn diagrams thinking
rationally we're very familiar with
these we said but a long with lists
arrays and trees thank you very much we
said we use their diagrams as one of our
rules and visualizing these probability
situations this is the real secret about
under what circumstances under what
circumstances of the diagram obey your
number that's right and from everybody's
needs to remember you can have a look
you can see all we've got well friends
and you've got nine people who ate meat
for dinner and seventy eight hours apply
when you take that citizen to nine yards
but one who may not like this doesn't at
all
is clearly some overlap between them
which is representative of perfectly in
the bedtime okay so this is what we use
one of the things you might remember and
I kind of just sort of like that that
didn't do any better
was that it's quite tricky taking that
information but those words from before
and then filling it into here like it's
not be straightforward you've got a sort
of thing about like oh what happens with
those group of people then how do you do
this and it's kind of a it's a bad
process right so what we want to do is
develop some notation to help us through
this process planning more logically and
systematically which is like well I'd
like you make a heading which is set
notation now hopefully some of this will
bring some bells from the past but
others of you live a worker bills at all
or you like other businesses who I we
could have showed you this last week and
give you all that theory and then used
all that to describe what's happening
yeah well I think it's much better than
have kind of way
it's set what's happening here and then
you can apply this very once the weather
looking for it's quite theoretical okay
so underneath this I want to talk to you
about what is it said and then how do we
describe it that's what this notation is
okay so that's not the definition a set
is very very simply this just what
you've got a bunch of objects all
together like for example you guys are a
set of Technology high school is a set
the things in your pencil case are set
so the most general way I would say is
it's a collection of objects it truly
can be anything now as you can imagine
in the context of whaling can't we're
often thinking about number it's like a
set of numbers but it doesn't have to be
for example have a look at this
situation that we had before right
you've got some sets he's some
collections of objects the to five
before the one what do they represent
they're not they represent people at
friends at the banquet right so it's
like we've got Aaron Johnny and with all
these people who eat here right so
they're after collection of objects now
how we describe that well let me give
some examples and this is where the UH
notation says in right so suppose I've
got my a servo video and my be set over
to be right I might say a equals and
then to indicate that it's a set it's a
collection of objects and you're going
to need practice for this is something
you might be good at straight away we
use curly braces to indicate
okay whatever is now to come here it's
not just done a set of numbers it's a
collection of objects they can be
anything so what I said and so on right
and then of course we started with curly
brace territory
- and so all I be here is these things
in here belong to that set of people who
may have a pipe or whatever now
importantly no one else you special do
you think it matters whose name that I
rode fest that doesn't right in fact
that's why there's a order indicated
here so I can just easily have reason
okay so please make that a defect before
it doesn't matter later on this will
become a little more but now just if I
then say I've gotten understand you
suppose the people so when I start to
list out all these other people right
you might remember when we were solving
this question what I was interested in
was for example other questions was her
name
both so if I wanted to describe who are
the people who are in both sets who in
that burglar who's in that five right
the where were you set notation to
describe that is interference some
people were innocent of all this upside
down looking you without a town on it so
this stands for a and that symbol means
intersection someone that means an
intersection and what it would mean is
the people who are in today and it said
they at the same time so another way
like color really I just think of that
as
so in this case I would have or the only
one I've written downloads in both at
the moment is just have with my name's
it's just parent in this case this
wasn't right so I'm gonna write it down
and I've got a few others as you can see
I'm just to zero but you get the idea
that these people on the road says okay
all right now in addition to having the
intersection I could say what and all
the people who paid either online or
leave I think ruly server both of them
if you don't have have to eat both at
the same time okay we use the same
signal but we turn it back around the
right way so we have a big without sorry
you have the tail on it and this simple
we are this actually does say for more
helpful that you kind of stands for this
word Union now when I say this one is
the overlap you kind of visualize that
if I say a union B I mean you're
anywhere we did this out anywhere at all
so when we use the word overlap it kind
of reads and that's kind of the clued in
time you push an apple pie and beef here
the weather croissants not and what
alternative views or I will buy all be
sure I'm going to write down everyone
who got God in these two sets together
[Music]
now these two are probably the key
pieces of step notation that we really
need along with these braces that I've
shown you before they're not quite the
only ones I'll come back to these in a
minute so I've printed out some stuff
for us but before we leave off all of
the let's have a nice logical and
comprehensive is anyway sometimes what
we want to know and it's what you can
see drawn on the Venn diagram is how
many things
what's the number of objects in a sense
what's the number of object in today or
what's the number of objects it's a bit
swedish like that like so in this
particular example we might have a plan
B what is the number of objects today
it's inclusive of everyone inside circle
ready
it says the tune and there's the 5 so
much might open and you could say just
in the same way that they would be
equals very good okay let's see if you
are on the right track er if I now say
this is a set of objects key a and how
many there are
this is how many is it be what if I
asked you for the set sorry the number
of objects in the set you what would
that be feedback what is a baby
it means unlike all-beef it's fine you
can have any of them right does this
equal to it if I say or does it include
this guy in you this is them having both
so I've got someone see the table and
they're eating boy and I asked you is
that person eating how big what would
you say person right there I think I'd
say yes I think you have priorities yes
is they are right how would I say I need
to use a different word
different if I want to exclude that
person I wanted to only include people
who take one or this one
what words means one and only one right
either/or so that work by there is what
in the case do you take away this for
now though I'm actually inclusive of
everything inside the circles yes so can
someone tell me what end should be
dismissed
it's 11 isn't it because there's that
one on the other side okay stay with me
let's do the interception look this is
the one I shaded in red right so this
should just be the five swarm route